is anyone else
what from the pills it just feels so
[ __ ] good
right
[Music]
so for over two decades at dogfish head
we've been pushing the envelope to put
exotic culinary ingredients into beer
from brown sugar to maple syrup to
pumpkin meat to you name it today i am
in burbank at the headquarters of
youtube juggernuts rhett and link to
take them on a journey to try some of
the craziest beers that exist in the
craft brewing movement right now and of
course we will be asking the
quintessential question that every
adventurous drinking adult wants to know
the answer to will it beer let's find
out
[Music]
wow rhett link i am psyched to be here
welcome to our office
this is a sick office this is sort of
like the fortress
of fearlessness oh wow oh we've never
considered it that you guys have been
fearless watching you just go for it and
put things inside your body that most
people keep on the outside of their body
we've made a lot of mistakes well you've
done some nice work
and if it gets views you we're kind of
beholden to it at this point you know so
i've gotten the pleasure of seeing you
guys eat tacos with i think pork blood
uh yeah
that was our first will it episode yeah
you'd think we would have stopped after
that the congealed blood is way worse
than anything from the genitals of an
animal really yeah i've had several
penises
several balls yeah
i don't think we tend to space it out
you got to pace yourself when it comes
to penis we make a living
off of eating things that scare us but
beer for the first time today yeah this
is a completely beer
dedicated episode yeah this is it as a
brewer i do feel like it's my vocational
duty
to take you on a journey of experimental
beers i love it you ready for this yes
for youtube stars rhett and link two
guys who have tasted almost everything
on the planet i had to break out one of
our most off-centered creations to date
chicha is inspired by an ancient
peruvian beverage made with human chewed
corn because there's enzymes in saliva
that convert starch to sugar for our
version 100 dogfish head co-workers
chewed on purple maize to unlock
fermentable sugars for the brew which
also included an infusion of fresh
strawberries and pink peppercorns the
results are sweet tart and 100 sanitary
thanks to the sterilizing boil
uh go ahead have a set
go ahead and have it
the the greens that are brewed with
whether it's barley or or
wheat or corn they usually have to be
ramped up with heat to convert starches
to fermentable sugars but you know what
else also converts starch to fermentable
sugars aliens
human saliva
there's an enzyme in our saliva that
basically will convert starch
to sugar and this is a beer that i
brewed with over a hundred of my
co-workers where we chewed purple
peruvian corn yeah
for uh
why'd you wait 24 hours why'd you wait
to tell us and then we made cakes out of
the corn and overnight the enzymes in
our saliva
converts
the starches to sugars
and then
there was like a point you seem so happy
drinking your own spin we boiled it i do
have to say it's sterile so it's oil for
safety exactly for your safety this beer
has been boiled post chewing and
spitting there's a trust exercise
happening here that you're already
breaking he was like let me tell you all
about it go ahead and drink it oh yeah
and then we're drinking and then he's
like giving us a thing what do you guys
think give me your spit man right yeah i
don't taste any spit at all i don't
taste corn either in a good way it just
tastes like a good beer to me dry it's a
little dry a little positive astringency
what else are you getting yeah i was
thinking positive astringent i was going
to say that until you did right i put it
all over my face and the skin just all
the wrinkles go away
you don't taste the hops though no it's
almost hardly any because it doesn't
have it exactly the government defines
beer where every beer has to have some
quantity of water you use tops and
barley in it but we can add other stuff
so we like waved a few
leafs of hops over this beer but hardly
any hot right just to make it legal just
to make it barley legal you know we spit
a lot into our spit buckets i'm gonna
start sending it to you yeah and you'll
make stuff you're
right
yeah we get a cut
[Music]
this is a dark beer that was aged on oak
bourbon barrels
[Music]
you want us to guess the abv
11.
it's pretty good
it's not great 12.2
pretty good oh that seems a little bit
better it must be 14. it is exactly
just over 18
what gosh that's more that's
significantly more than wine exactly
usually wines about 10 or 12. what have
you done
right so millions of yeast cells got
together
acetomasochistic yeast cells because at
a certain point the alcohol the yeast
creates becomes toxic to the cell wall
of the yeast and kills it which is why
you can't have a beer or wine that's as
strong as a vodka or gin or something
that's distilled i don't know if it's
because it's dark but it has a little
bit of a molasses
molasses yeah because there's a lot of
unfermentable sugars still left in it
because the yeast couldn't eat all the
sugars that are in it so it's sweeter
and a little more yeah raisiny molasses
these are really good what do you call
it descriptor it's called worldwide
stout
when i brewed it it was 1999 and when i
first designed the label it said brewed
with
ridiculous amount of barley
and vim and vigor and the federal
government made me change the label
because you can't have the word vigor
on a beer label because it connotes
strength and you can't entice people to
buy something based on alcohol content
what i couldn't afford to buy new labels
so i hand crossed out the word vigor on
20 000
but you did it vigorously
[Music]
all right guys this is it a sort of
finish line
okay kind of finish line uh so usually
modern beers are fermented with very
specific yeast strains where you know
brewing scientists are looking under a
microscope to make sure it's the exact
same strain but long ago it was
considered a miracle the process of
fermentation because humans didn't
understand what that was so what it was
is wild yeast and bacteria that would
eat sugar and still today there's a
style called lambic which is still very
popular in and around brussels where
they literally open the roof of these
breweries and let the micro flora and
fauna come in from the night air and
wild yeast and wild bacteria is what
does the fermentation converting
the sugars whatever is in the air so
every batch was a little bit different
yeah exactly so the yeast decided what
that beer should taste like it was it's
so cool like when i've visited breweries
in brussels they won't wash the room the
rooms cover like cobwebs and dust and
[ __ ] but they don't want to [ __ ] with
their tawar so they leave the room all
dirty because the dirt is their brand
you know it's like an old cast iron
skillet yeah you don't you don't want to
wash it with soap right
exactly so this is a beautiful american
interpretation
of a belgian style lambic by our friends
at the brewery b-r-u-e-r-y
orange county okay let's do this
[Music]
that has got a sourness to it
it kind of has that like like a
double fermented sort of you know that
when you get one of those
acidic it's like eating a grapefruit
rind almost like bam yeah but take the
first sip let your pal acclimate to the
that tartness that acid i like it though
you know i like sour did you like it on
first sip or something yeah i i did i
mean it was shocking
but wow i really like sour stuff
i think i'm blind guys really i think i
can't see
with sours like this a positive
descriptor is horse blanket you're
looking for a smell of horse blanket
where's blanket do you get or splank it
in the nose of this beer maybe old
sleeping bag
there's a little barnyard thing
so this is the last
beer
that's on our journey but it's not the
last stop okay oh there's one more stop
on the train
crazy yes
so we are going next to a place called
miracle berry
i we know about the
miracle tell me talk about this was
ibuprofen
now you know that is a great way to
prevent a hangover okay but it's not
it is a miracle berry pill in extract
form and basically they call it taste
tripping yeah so tell me about your guys
first experience we've tried this once
and
you keep it on your tongue for a while i
think it takes away your ability to
taste sour which makes you interpret
sour as sweet wow so i'm like literally
the only miracle berry virgin
in the room right now so with all
apologies to
the brewery and this beautiful
intentional sour yeah take this miracle
berry we're gonna try and see how this
beer evolves
post-dosing
[Music]
did you chew yours yeah
where is it it's moving around
tastes good doesn't it
it's bearish
for sure
is anyone else feeling from the pill
like you're caressing me
is there anyone else
what
from the pills it just feels so [ __ ]
good
right
no you guys that's just me
yeah i see what you mean i don't feel
that way either
you got a different one buddy yeah yeah
all right instead of that let's eat
lemons let's see lemons it's like
watching baseball right
[Music]
okay here we go
weird
wow
it's like eating an orange even sweeter
it's so sweet it's way sweeter than an
orange it's so sweet that means it's
working so we did the lemon test
and now for the what's this beer gonna
taste like this is like in the fireworks
show when at the end they just [ __ ]
go for it and the sky is a glow yeah
this is it the finale guys what is your
saying dink it
and sink sink
[Music]
unbelievable
there's not a hint
of sour
it tastes
like a super sweet grape it's still good
but in a completely different way yeah
this is my favorite both sides of it the
sour post yes both sides give me one of
these on a friday night yeah first half
of the bottle as is then you you do the
taste tripping and then you finish it up
they should sell these at the bar man
beer nuts and miracle berries
i'd do that
[Music]
closing comments where you thought your
beer journey was gonna go and where it
went well i mean typically
when we do something like this
we would save the human spit
for the last round but i like the fact
that right out of the gate you just made
us drink spit
did not expect that
it only got better from there and you
know what i'll never forget you this is
a life-changing experience for me yeah
it was odd and that's our speed man and
we loved it and we did drink it
this has been fun right
thank you guys for letting us into your
beautiful domicile keep challenging
people yeah yeah yeah keep going for it
cheers
[Music]
you